Would you like a chocolate?
Oh, thank you.
Forrest Gump
was in Savannah, Georgia,
a town with interesting history.
But tour guides say,
The number one question I get is,
"Where's the bench in Forrest Gump?"
Michelle Freenor
offers walking tours.
We are gonna do a
90 minute history tour of Savannah.
She gets good reviews from customers.
But her business
almost didn't get off the ground
because
Savannah's politicians say
to be a tour guide
you have to get a license.
I had to pass a
college-level
history exam
with tons of
obscure gotcha questions.
It could be
three to five months
of studying and studying it
because it was about
120 pages.
I had to
map out
where I was standing,
what I was saying.
Tour guides
need licenses?
In some cities
you have to have a license
just to tell stories.
Dick Carpenter,
author of the book Bottleneckers
Gaming Government
for Power
and Private Profit
says Savannah's rules,
like those in many cities
create
so many hurdles
for entrepreneurs.
Not only did Michelle
have to pass
a difficult history test,
she also had to do a criminal background check,
which meant she had to give
a urine sample
and a blood sample.
She also had to
go through a physical fitness test
And then she had to pay
fees to the city as a result.
A hundred dollars
and yet the test
asked no questions about
subjects covered
by the most popular tours.
You know the most popular tour
in Savannah
is a ghost tour.
So she complained
to a city official.
There's no ghost questions on this test
and he goes
because ghosts aren't real.
There were no questions about
the making of Forrest Gump either.
Stupid is as stupid does.
Even if guides give
Forrest Gump tours,
ghost tours,
or food tours,
they had to take the test.
The city was making a nice amount
of money
for
people failing this.
A lot of people think that this fee is just
another money grab by the city.
Alderman Bill Durrance says
It's important
to license tour guides.
I hear a lot of tour guides
saying things that make me cringe
because it's just not accurate information
and so
the licensing and the testing,
I thought was a good idea
just to make sure people had
the accurate Information.
Politicians
in a bunch of other cities agree.
They demand
tour guides pass a test.
The turning point for Michelle came
when she got sick.
When I told them,
hey I don't think I could pass the physical this year,
I was actually told
by a city official,
"Well I guess you're gonna have to find
another occupation."
There were a couple of points
that maybe
went a little too far
in the licensing process.
Having to have the physical exam
periodically,
maybe the cost of the test.
They basically said that if you don't like it
you can sue us
and when they said that,
that's what I did.
With the help of the law firm
the Institute for Justice,
she sued Savannah
and Savannah
removed its licensing rule.
So how does that go down?
You bring the suit
and they sheepishly say,
oh yeah, you're right,
it's a First Amendment issue?
Mmm I wish it were that easy.
There's discovery,
depositions are taken
and so the city often
Months? Years?
Months,
often years.
They realized
that this, was in fact,
a First Amendment issue
and they stood to lose.
Savannah was just one of their victories.
You want a Washington DC tour?
Just ten dollars!
That's the Capital behind me.
This is the IRS building.
Oh I can't tell you that.
That's
illegal.
Washington DC
once demanded
that guides have a license.
So I joined this segway tour.
Aren't they trying to make sure that
people get a proper tour?
We give them a proper tour.
I mean,
I've passed a bar exam.
I know how to give a proper tour.
The Institute for Justice
sued Washington, too
and won.
So now at least
in DC and Savannah,
tour guides are free to work.
The free market
is taking care of itself.
Bad tour companies
don't last.
It's been a pleasure walking with you today.
She's right.
Competition protects
consumers
better than licensing laws
ever will.
But politicians
always want
more control
over you.
Little by little
we've managed to get control of some things
but we still
don't have control
over a lot.
Yes you do.
Your bottlenecks
are everywhere
So I'm glad
there are people out there
trying to stop them.
In our next bottlenecker video,
we'll cover
the fight over
food trucks.
I could have lost it all.